hello everyone my name is ashwaraj
srinivasan and i am a ai nml innovation
leader here at ibm
what we see in the current knowledge era
is that the volume of data has increased
tremendously but the amount of
information extracted from the data
hasn't increased as much
which leads to the knowledge gap with
the unused data
the total accumulated data has grown
from 4.4 zetabytes in 2013 to 44 zeta
bytes in 2020. so we have accumulated
nine times more data just in those seven
years
but we haven't been leveraging all this
data
now this data can be anywhere
different industries organizations local
businesses individuals store their data
in various sources
it could be oracle db2 sql server
postgres mongodb etc which should now be
residing on multiple platforms it could
be on cloud on premises and mainframes
and can be in various formats
relational non-relational nosql
the challenge comes when we want to use
all of these data sources for analytics
and to build models
so what's the best way to move data
to not move it at all
this is where data virtualization comes
into play data virtualization is a
technique to connect all the data
sources seamlessly and securely in a
single location
with these capabilities we can query all
the data sources as if they reside in
one single space
this would significantly reduce costs
and complexities of data engineering
simplify data management and improve
collaboration with centralized access
when working with such large volumes of
data governance also comes into play
which is what is addressed in data
virtualization
as an overview data virtualization
consists of three layers
the bottom layer is the connection layer
that interacts with the databases that
we need
the next is the virtualization layer
that is used to build optimized queries
virtual tables and scale while
preserving the performance with parallel
processing
now the third layer is the consumer
layer which has all the user interface
through which one can build views and
query them with this we have a
complementary layer we have the
governance catalogs that pulls metadata
from across different sources and builds
on business terms
data lineage data privacy and protection
rules
with this we can have a controlled
governed and secure access to virtual
data sets
let's dig a little deeper into this
with data virtualization we can achieve
faster data exploration collaborative
high paralleled compute models provide
superior memory performance compared to
federation
up to
430 percent faster against 100 terabytes
of datasets
secondly when running queries on these
datasets we need to build optimized
versions for better modeling
the results is faster insights to your
team with some queries being completed
up to 8 to 10 times faster as measured
by ibm's internal testing
third is cost saving
data virtualization leads to
significantly lower costs for
infrastructure and reduces time spent on
managing data which has a direct effect
on your organization's bottom line
this solution helps enterprises minimize
the required storage of data copies
while still remaining continuity between
compressed and optimized versions of the
source or on production data
finally virtual data pipeline can be
used as a storage backup and recovery
capability and expands to cover test
data management and analytics data
pipeline
so with data virtualization
organizations can view
access
manipulate and analyze data without
worrying about the physical location
to learn more about data virtualization
do visit our website
you